the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thursday and
house of the dragon video in this video
i will be giving my initial thoughts on
the very first episode of hbo's new game
of thrones series house of the dragon
well my friends the day we have all been
waiting for is finally here now i don't
usually do this but now that house of
the dragon is actually here i think it
should be celebrated
now i gotta be honest i wasn't sure if
this day would ever come after the
divisive game of thrones ending and the
cancelling of the long night series i
did wonder if something would happen to
house of the dragon before it actually
aired thankfully it is finally here and
i must say the very first episode was
great the first thing i want to do is
get into some of the things i liked
about this episode i think this first
episode did a great job at setting
everything up for this first season
right out of the gate we are shown that
the matter of succession will be the
main conflict of this series something
that is very reminiscent of game of
thrones i mean it's no secret why the
main series as well as george r martin's
first novel in the song of ice and fire
series is named game of thrones the
matter of succession will be the
backbone of this new show and it wasn't
long before we started seeing how this
would affect each of the new characters
in house of the dragon now before i get
into all of that i want to mention the
first scene after the cold opening again
i have to be honest i would be lying if
i said i didn't feel a little emotional
when the music swelled right at the
beginning of this episode when we saw
rhaenyra flying over the red keep for
the first time it felt amazing to
finally be back in westeros again they
did a great job at making this feel like
we're right back in game of thrones
without making it feel like the exact
same show there's something about the
whole aesthetic of this show that i
really like i don't know why but most of
the scenes that are shot outside make me
feel like i'm walking around inside of a
dream i don't know if it's the effects
they use or some sort of filter but the
whole aesthetic is great if you ask me
it was actually nice seeing the red keep
alive and filled with friendly visitors
at the beginning unlike in game of
thrones where it almost always had this
ominous and dark feeling whenever we
were inside of this castle i thought
this was a good way of setting up who
viserys targaryen is we immediately see
how viserys targaryen is unlike many of
the other kings we have seen or heard of
before
he is a nice guy although he might be a
little soft for the iron throne it was
interesting how we kept seeing the iron
throne make him bleed foreshadowing how
he might not be sitting there for much
longer now as soft as viserys is i also
did like that we finally saw he does
have some fire inside of him when he
started flexing his muscles near the end
of the episode when everyone started
telling him who he should name as his
successor i also really like how they
set up serato hightower easily one of my
favorite characters to watch already
he's not going to let someone walk all
over him and he's not afraid to speak
his mind even when he's addressing the
king about his very own brother serato
gives me those little finger vibes
especially after the way he had his
daughter go visit viserys after his wife
and son had just died he let us know
right away that he does have his eye set
on the iron throne even if that means
sacrificing his own daughter's innocence
now as disgusting as that might be and
as hateable as he might become i think
it makes for a very interesting
character i thoroughly enjoyed his
interactions with daemon targaryen as
well they set up their relationship and
hatred for one another right away and it
should make for some very interesting
scenes in the future another one of my
favorite moments from this episode was
daemon's introduction now i will say no
ones will ever be as great as lord tywin
lannisters but i still enjoyed his
nonetheless it sort of reminded me of
jaime lannister's scene when ned stark
saw him sitting in front of the iron
throne when he arrived in king's landing
any dominance daemon might have lacked
in the first scene was certainly made up
for in a second when we meet him in a
city watch he immediately made a
statement to everyone living in that
city his justice is vicious but i must
say it did help the first half of this
episode for me because the beginning did
feel like a slow burn although it was
very understandable because they had to
set everything up the addition of
several targaryens speaking in high
valyrian is great as well it further
demonstrates just how different these
targaryens are from everyone else as if
their hair and dragon riding wasn't
enough
now speaking of the dragons they look
amazing as well having this many big ass
dragons in the very first episode alone
lets us know this isn't your daddy's
game of thrones show we don't have to
wait several seasons before we start
seeing massive dragons flying around in
the sky house of the dragon is giving us
that right out of the gate i also love
just how different some of them look
from daenerys dragons i mean daemon's
dragon actually does look like a damn
bloodworm with its long neck and body it
looks kind of odd at first but i really
like it because it does make him stand
out from the rest unlike game of thrones
they're finally giving all these dragons
their own characteristics they've always
deserved i really like rhaenyra and
alison's relationship in the episode
their friendliness and fondness of one
another is only setting up even greater
scenes down the road once they have
their falling out it will make their
relationship even more heartbreaking
once we see how violent things actually
get once the dance of the dragons begins
now one thing i was not expecting was
the scene with viserys targaryen's wife
emma aaron i must say the scene of her
giving birth to their son was brutal and
i was not expecting to see viceros make
the decision to save the sun now they
made it obvious how badly he wanted a
son but it did not seem like he would do
that after the way they were setting him
up this does seem like an afterthought
however after watching his wife lose her
life for the sun this might sound messed
up but for me this is when the episode
really started to get good i thought the
second half of this episode was a lot
better than the first once they had most
of the main characters established
now if you're someone who has read fire
and blood or even a song of ice and fire
i'm sure you notice how fast and loose
they were with some of the source
material jaehaerys shouldn't have been
there during the great council rainey's
son should have been there during the
election and the werewolf shouldn't have
been in king's landing either and so on
and so forth i don't think it should
have a major effect on the overall story
although the verdict is still out until
we see the rest of the episodes from
this season like i said earlier i think
this was a great episode to start off
the show the only thing it was really
missing is one of those big major
moments like game of thrones first
episode had if you remember that first
episode began with the white walkers and
it ended with bran being thrown from the
window this episode did not necessarily
have one of those hooks or cliffhangers
like the original series but there are
many amazing moments still to come for
my initial thoughts i say they did a
great job at reintroducing everyone to
westeros it did a great job at setting
up who everyone is and their
relationships with one another as always
the sets look amazing the costumes look
phenomenal and the overall production is
what you would expect from an hbo series
as you can imagine i'm very interested
and eager to see where everything goes
from here on out let me know what you
thought about everything down below i
will be making my full breakdown video
in the following days as well as my
teaser breakdown video for the next
episode make sure you subscribe now
because i will be making a lot of videos
during each and every week of this
season as always i want to thank
everyone for watching this video i hope
you all have a great day i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you